quelques centaines de mètres après le
carrefour qui mène aux trois ilets
c'est le lieu d'une arrestation musclée
qui a eu lieu en début d'après midi
l'individu interpellé par les forces de
gendarmerie était activement recherché
après avoir tiré un coup de feu dans une
discothèque de rivière salée dans la
nuit du 3 au 4 novembre
aujourd'hui un peu avant midi il a été
repéré aux anses d'arlet après une
course poursuite
il a forcé un barrage de gendarmerie et
l'individu a été finalement interpellé
après une course folle
l'intervention de l'hélicoptère et
plusieurs unités de gendarmerie ont été
nécessaires pour venir à bout du forcené